this is what preparation for the
australian open has become for top
women's player onshore
and her team
[Applause]
[Music]
across this hotel in melbourne are
similar scenes of resourcefulness
mattresses propped against the walls
waste paper bins for targets
even the window has become a hitting
partner
the international travel rules state
that everyone arriving in australia must
isolate for 14 days
tennis players were given special
dispensation
to leave their rooms for five hours
training every day
but now 72 of them almost one quarter of
the total field
have to isolate completely after people
on their charter flights here tested
positive for coronavirus
this is the worst part of quarantine
i don't wash my own hair i've never
washed my own hair it's just not
something that i do
and some aren't happy saying they
wouldn't have traveled at all if the
rules had been made
clearer bernard thomas and his
girlfriend vanessa
have been chronicling their quarantine
online when you do order your food they
have to inspect it and i don't know what
the hell they do by the time the food
comes to you it's so cold
world number one and player
representative novak djokovic has asked
for better food
and players to be moved to private homes
with tennis courts
british wheelchair tennis star gordon
reed is also in quarantine but says some
players need a reality check
i would say it's a minority of the
players that
um are kind of kicking up a fuss but a
lot of times
that minority are the loudest ones and
the most vocal so it maybe comes across
that is
more people than it actually is there's
little sympathy too
from the thousands of australian
citizens stranded abroad
it's the situation for so many
australians and i'd be
happy i would be more than happy to be
in their situation and be in my own
country right now
and so for the next 10 days britain's
heather watson and other stars
will continue to play tennis without a
court and in some cases without a ball
but with 57 000 pounds on offer even for
first round losers at the australian
open
it may be a price worth paying martha
kellner
sky news